[Music]
you've heard the stories
ceos waking up at 4am to kickstart their
day with workouts
online meetings a power breakfast then
physical meetings in their workplace
working a crazy number of hours having
like 10 minutes for lunch
and coming home to work until midnight
ultimately getting only 4 hours of sleep
i'm tired just thinking about it is that
routine realistic
maybe not we know for sure apple ceo tim
cook wakes up at 3 45 in the morning to
go through over 700 emails and user
feedback before hitting the gym at five
o'clock
and elon musk with everything he has
going on certainly doesn't get enough
sleep in today's
environment where entrepreneurship is
idolized there's still a bit of mystery
surrounding exactly what a modern tech
ceo does on a daily basis
well we've gone ahead and compiled a
rundown of what we consider
a typical tech ceo's day looks like but
before we dive in
welcome back to our channel if you
haven't already make sure you hit that
subscribe button and ring the bell so
you're notified every time we upload a
new video
jeff bezos starts his day around seven
in the morning and he likes to take his
sweet time
he doesn't go to the gym or do anything
particularly strenuous that early in the
morning
but instead likes to kick back with a
cup of coffee and a paper
he did announce he's stepping down from
his role as ceo of amazon
but he hasn't yet so he's still
following his daily routine
some people believe amazon is
technically a retail company and not a
tech company
well the term has become rather fuzzy in
recent years
but a tech company is one that heavily
relies on technology to exist
which definitely includes amazon
successful people will often wake up
early to avoid procrastination
and they will spend their mornings
either meditating or catching up on the
news
but mark zuckerberg after waking up at
eight in the morning
checks facebook facebook messenger and
whatsapp there's a ceo we can all relate
to
their breakfast will either be protein
rich or really sweet to give them a
sugar rush to start the day
think pancakes waffles french toast
sometimes with bacon and eggs bezos
enjoys blueberry chocolate chip pancakes
which he once cooked up with sierra and
russell wilson on tv
tim cook on the other hand prefers egg
whites sugar-free cereal
and unsweetened almond milk when he
starts his day some ceos like sundar
pachai will keep it simple
basic toast and eggs with an english tea
and of course
we can't forget the coffee it's fuel for
the day now when you get to work you
don't want to be bombarded with problems
and spend your whole day working on them
while you neglect your other tasks
jeff bezos will not take any meetings
before 10 am
because he believes it's not until then
when his brain is performing at its best
and he would like to conduct meetings
and make decisions during that time
sundar pachai will start meetings once
he's in office but he prefers to take
them on the go
he's known to wander off in the middle
of a meeting but he will return later
with a solution to whatever issue was
being discussed
now if you're running a company like
google or tesla there will be several
teams you need to meet with
this is an important part of the day to
ensure you and your team are on the same
page
just make sure it's a productive meeting
and not one that wastes everybody's time
elon musk for example is known to simply
get up and leave meetings that he feels
is wasting his time
jeff bezos strongly discourages
powerpoint presentations in his
conferences
and prefers everybody to engage in a
conversation rather than listen to one
person talk
some days for a ceo primarily consists
of networking and connecting with other
industry leaders
other mornings it's all about solving
problems and talking with sales
distribution marketing and c-level
executives
and of course customer service jeff
bezos especially spends a majority of
his time in the customer service and
research offices
because he realized his company's
biggest selling points aside from the
extensive inventory
are quick delivery and good customer
service he's always trying to up the
game and improve on customer experience
which is why amazon is as successful as
it is
ceos also use this as a time to look
forward in research market trends
foresight is an essential trait in any
leader amazon started as a book reseller
and grew to what it is today
but bezos didn't forget where he started
first he knew an electronic reader would
be hugely successful and created kindle
which now dominates the e-reader market
they hold 75 percent market share in
america and 95
in the united kingdom a good ceo is also
one that knows when to quit
elon musk jumped on the battery swap
technology to offer his customers faster
charging times for their electric cars
he did the research and found a way to
complete the swap process
in 90 seconds but seeing the lukewarm
reception it got he decided to leave the
project
instead of pursuing it even more right
about now
it's lunchtime this will either be a
business lunch where you have another
few meetings while shoveling down your
calories for the day
or you take some time out for yourself
and eat alone
elon musk will often eat wherever he can
admitting that his nutrition
isn't very good when he's working tim
cook on the other hand
eats his lunch with random employees in
the cafeteria
mark zuckerberg will often skip meals
and it's become so common that his
parents once
asked him if they should send over some
food as you've probably guessed
being a ceo is not a typical
nine-to-five job
five o'clock is just your midway point
especially if you are startup
even if you aren't a startup chances are
you'll work crazy hours
elon musk for example works 100 hours a
week
mark zuckerberg in comparison pulls
around 50 hours a week
most ceos will head home for dinner then
continue working from home
others might actually wind down with
family and may be unplugged from
technology
some of the world's most successful
founders swear by innovating and
progressing their companies through
personal development
this is the time they will often use to
read books and articles or listen to a
podcast
mark zuckerberg once challenged himself
to read one new book
every two weeks jeff bezos credits books
for his leadership style
some billionaire ceos recommend reading
an average of a hundred pages a day
that's a big bite to chew if you're
working on getting your startup off the
ground but when you can afford to spend
that kind of time it's not a bad idea
it certainly gives you an edge over your
competitors of course
every ceo will have a different daily
routine there are some slow days
and others will feel like chaos all ceos
from zuckerberg and bezos to those of
small startups
agree that running a company isn't
always glamorous but routine leads to
efficiency
and creates a sense of stability inside
the organization
would you do things differently if you
were ceo let us know in the comments
below
if you enjoyed this video make sure you
hit the like button and watch more like
it on the simply tech channel
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time